c'est la folie des pokémon nous y avons
consacré une émission il ya quelques
semaines sur région pointent comme et
cette mode n'est pas encore retombée ces
images à collectionner font un tabac
dans les cours de récréation mais aussi
dans les salles de classe et c'est bien
le problème
les élèves sont moins attentifs du coup
dans certaines écoles ont confisqué que
ces pokémon et on envisage même de les
interdire
reportage de france 3 à amiens voici des
pokémon mais s'écarte là sont déjà
réservées dans les bureaux de tabac sont
en rupture de stock depuis plusieurs
mois pourtant la demande est toujours
très forte
mais maman surtout viennent pour les
enfants parce que les enfants réclament
à cor et à cri mais mais quand la
possible on peut pas vraiment facile a
enfin on essaie de les faire patienter
un petit peu devant madame pour mieux
comprendre il faut aller dans les cours
d'école l'ambiance est frénétique on y
rencontre des gentils pokémon des
méchants pokémon explication est à peu
près comme une bête
et puis ça soit ça pokémon sol feu air
eau
pourquoi c'est intéressant ça passe à la
télé et oui les pokémon c'est surtout un
grand phénomène médiatique et commercial
qui peut perturber la quiétude des
salles de classe via des échanges entre
l image presque à l'armement de le
collectionneur de ces images-là et
donc c'est vrai que ça sommes plus
beaucoup leur esprit comme ces petits
c'est très facile de mettre dans la
poche bon pièce moyenne les chouchous
sont vendus avec qu'on retrouva partout
dans la cour et même dans les salles des
thèmes pas évident car pour l'instant
ici les pokémon ne sont pas interdits
d'école même si des collections ont déjà
été confisqués mais il ne faut pas
oublier que c'est avant tout une mode
qui passera sans doute même si pour
l'instant elle reste bien ancré sur les
têtes